des images qui parlent d'elle-même mais
qui se multiplient ces derniers jours
dans certains états musulmans depuis
près d'une semaine
plusieurs pays ont manifesté contre la
france et emmanuel macron après ses
propos sur la liberté d'expression et le
droit de caricaturé le prophète nommé à
dacca au bangladesh
comme à jakarta en indonésie des
milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées ce lundi dans un climat
hostile les participants ont scandé des
slogans appelant au boycott de
marchandises françaises
nous avons boycotter des produits
l'oréal paris et tous les produits de
paris ou de france que nous avons à
cause de ce qu'ils font et de ce qu'ils
ont dit sur notre prophète alors nous
boycottons ses produits pour pouvoir
leur montrer notre pouvoir des
manifestations qui se multiplient dans
les pays musulmans et qui inquiète la
france endeuillée à plusieurs reprises
par plusieurs attentats islamistes ces
derniers jours face à cette défiance
plusieurs fédérations nationales
musulmane et grande mosquée condamne je
cite les appels injustifiés au boycott
des produits français
notre condamnation des appels
injustifiés au boycott des produits
français
les médias de france est en libre aucun
responsable politique y compris le
président de la république française ne
peut imposer à un organe de presse
une publication ou une non publication
d'un dessin ou d'une caricature aussi
nous considérons que ces appels sont
infondées et reposent sur des
manipulations politiques
cachant d'autre objectif que la défense
de l'islam
le ministre français des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian a appelé
les ressortissants français vivant à
l'étranger à la prudence estimant je
cite que la menace contre les intérêts
français était partout